Today, we need to move on to Eid, Eid
al-Fitr.
Which is a wonderful celebration for the
Muslims. But, I would very much like you
now to define the term Eid.
The word Eid means something which is
habitual.
It also means
to return.
It also means to repeat. In short, Eid
means
it is a recurring event.
And
it can also be used
for
a particular place which
people visit periodically.
It can also mean
a time period
where a particular act is done
regularly.
The plural of Eid is Eid.
It is a day of gathering.
The Eid is derived from the Arabic word
ada
which means to return. And people return
this event every year. That's Eid. And
Ibn al-Arabi
he says
that the reason Eid is called because it
returns the happiness every year.
And the word Eid some people say is also
derived from ada
which means the custom, which means
tradition. So, people are accustomed to
celebrating Eid. Therefore, the word Eid
is there.
According to Muslim Ahmad volume number
three, hadith number 12006.
Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wasallam
one day enters
the city of Medina.
And
before in the days of
Jahiliyyah, in the days of ignorance,
the people of Medina used to celebrate
two days
of sports and amusement.
One was
the day of Nayruz
which was the new year. The other was
the day of Maharajan
which was the final day of the year.
So, Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam says
that you people in the days of
Jahiliyyah
used to celebrate two days with sports
and amusement. Now, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala replaced it with two better days.
The day of Nahr, that is the day of
sacrifice, and the day of Fitr, that is
the day of breaking, indicating the
Eidain, the two Eid we have, Eid al-Adha
and the Eid al-Fitr. They are replaced
with the previous days of Jahiliyyah.
So, here we come to know that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has replaced the
days of Jahiliyyah where people used to
enjoy with play and amusement with days
that are better, day of sacrifice, day
of forgiveness, etc., which is much
better for them for this world as well
as for dunya and akhirah.